okay so this this talk is actually
uh we saw yesterday then in the
introduction
you know a large fraction of the
participant to this
coding theory workshop are not coding
theorists and
proudly so so so
so i will actually i i
i don't know how to classify myself but
i will i will actually i think that
it's a good idea uh to spend the ten
minutes since this is the
first talk doing some coding theory
right and so i'll
i'll uh
talk about to give you know a crash
course into
the part of coding theory that i find
most interesting that is codes on graph
and probabilistic decoding
just at high level and then what i'll
try to do is that i'll try to put
you know these uh things in a broader
context
by describing basically a short list of
problems the list might be
much longer in which very similar things
seem to pop up
okay so people that know about coding
theorists might say
about this part might say haha this is
the same as
and yeah so two weeks you know
disclaimers i will not state formal
theorems you can ask for
for them if you want but you know in the
interest of time i'll try to be
uh very synthetic and so not going to
many detail and of course i'll give some
a few examples and please interrupt me
you know
so this is the more detailed outline and
the three examples are basically chosen
because
they are easily connected to the first
part
so codes on graph okay so this is the
picture
you want to send bits to a noisy channel
and say that the model is that you know
each observation is the original bit
plus a bernoulli random variable with
bias p
and uh you know the
scores the way they work is
that you don't send any sequence of bits
but only those that satisfy
a set of parity checks that here you
represent i represent is a graph
and each of those these nodes means that
mod to sum of uh you know
the variables here have to be zero and
only those
you know words that satisfies these
constraints are
are valid code words okay
and you know if you accept these as the
code that you want to use
really what what what is the problem the
problem will be
estimate the excise given observations
now the observation y
so you want to use somehow the noise
observation and the structure
okay yeah of course you know as we saw
yesterday there is 40 years
you know or 50 years history of you know
analysis of these codes
and so i'll give the two slides summary
of what is known
and you know i focus on what is known on
you know
large block length so you take such a
graph
as block length to infinity now how you
construct such a graph
basically all the construction boys boil
down to the following
take a random graph with some
constraints okay so
now of course the the devil is
in the details in particular what
constraint you want to put and people
came up with very smart way of imposing
these constraints
the simplest that dated back to
gallagher is simply
imposed the degree to some given value
but people came up with much smarter
ways that
allowed to achieve capacity
okay so very nice and interesting rough
ensembles to study
uh okay so what is the the generic
behavior so this is the plot that refers
to uh the simplest
possible of this code the rate one half
code would
give three on this side and six on that
side
this is rate one half and what i plot
here in x-axis is basically
noise level and the y-axis the
the performance so zero means zero
decoding error and one means
you know complete rubbish and
uh you know more precisely uh you know
two nice coordinates that is nice to use
is to plot
on the x-axis the entropy of the channel
flip probability
this is nice because it's between 0 and
1 for any channel
and you know y-axis something that is
similar to entropy and
it has this form
you take any your favorite algorithm
this will output soft decisions that is
estimates of the
posterior probability of each bit i so
call this
p i arg you compute some
function g of this so think of this as
entropy it's not the entropy but there's
many properties of the entropy is
increasing in particular
it's between 0 and one and average these
over all the beats
okay so this zero means that you are
decoding perfectly and one you are you
are getting complete rubbish
and this is the picture
if you apply you know uh
you know a local decoder that is belief
propagation
uh this gives you know perfect decoding
below a certain threshold
and then you know follows a certain
curve above
the threshold so this is the threshold
for that
decoder now this figure instead refers
to the ideal decoder
that is the decoder that computes this
pi
uses this returns this pi as the
posterior
probabilities so p i will be the
posterior probability that
bit i is 1 given all the observations
this is something that you cannot
compute in general you do not compute in
general
but you can analyze and turns out that
the threshold of this is related to the
threshold of this
algorithm by very interesting and simple
construction
you just look at this curve and set
find the vertical line where these two
area match
so you cut any vertical curve cuts a
slice here and slice here
and you find where the two area so you
get two thresholds
both threshold are below 0.5
okay so just sanity check why they are
below 0.5
to see whether anybody is following
did you say which code you're using yeah
yeah
all right somebody want to answer is it
the 360
yeah so it's written one half
so one half here is shown on upper
bounds that is shown on capacitor
okay so these are the generic features
that you know
i want to remember of this picture
okay there is phase transitions there is
a phase transition for local algorithms
you know in this case it's belief
propagation
uh so what i mean by this is this is an
algorithm that for each
vertex computes p i arg just by looking
at the bounded depth neighborhood
of vertex i in the graph for any bounded
depth
and this has a certain phase transition
there is an information theoretic phase
transition
this is the information phase transition
of that code
is at age map and interestingly enough
you know despite probably again 60 50
years of research
nobody knows any polynomial algorithm
that works in this interval
and you know recent discovery
is that you can take the graph and
massage it a little bit
to this special coupling technique in
such a way that
the bp threshold becomes sequel to the
map threshold
and the slice gets cut off completely
this is kind of magic the first time
that you see but that's
that's true okay
sorry so special coupling is pornography
time or
so special coupling opposing statements
so special coupling
is a modification of the graph
so you take your graph so what i said is
that
the graph is random with some
constraints you can think of special
coupling adding a little bit more
constraints
it's interesting because the graph
remains basically very similar to the
original graph
and similarly enough that all this part
of the curve for instance remains the
same
but it is not you know it's different
enough
to to slice away this curve okay
so it's kind of a magic you know trick
that take you know a problem that is npr
then
you know changes it into a problem that
is you know
solvable under you know local algorithm
and that
uh has
you know very similar properties
okay so this was uh the course encoding
theory
and uh so now we are all coming first
and so now do it two examples in which
similar things happens
surprisingly one is compressed sensing
okay so
so here the model that i want to look at
is the following uh
you have a vector x of length capital n
so it's a big vector
you hit it with a matrix and the matrix
is
a random metric say a random metrics
with id
normal zero one over entry and the
matrix is known of the decode at the
decoder
they observe y so y is a times x plus
some noise well the observe is y
and a and you want to reconstruct x
naught
okay so at high level
looks very similar to the thing before
you have some unknown bits or some
unknown variable here they are not bits
and you have some noisy observations
and now the problem is is is dense
this matrix is dense there is no natural
notion of locality
so what i want to replace uh
for locality is a class of algorithms
that takes this form
one way to see them is you know as a
limit for dense graph of the algorithms
of leaf propagation
approximate message passing and the way
they work is basically
they apply a a transpose and then they
do some non-linear operation
so at each iteration you take your
current estimate
uh you know you subtract your current
estimate you subtract it from the
from the observation you construct the
residual
and then you you know back project with
a transpose and then you do some
nonlinear operation
there are many ways of deriving this i
will not go into detail
one way is again you take problem or
sparse graph
take belief propagation for that problem
and then you formally take somehow
a good approximation for the degree
getting larger
okay and so now one
interesting difference between this
problem and
and the original problem that i want to
retain and that is important
is that in the coding problem you know
the distribution of x naught
because you know the code the decoder
knows the code
knows that you know whoever is
transmitting is sampling a code
word uniformly at random in this problem
you don't know the real distribution of
x naught
so you can think of two cases two limits
cases
one is you know a prior exactly this is
idealized and lower bound and so at each
step
in that case the prescription is that
here you want to do the mmsc denoiser
for decoding and the other extreme you
don't know the
prior but you know some feature of x not
for instance that is sparse
in that case you want to use it each
step the the
the minimax denoiser for that class
that is basically the best denoiser for
the worst distribution in the
class okay so these are example
so so so what happens the first
discovery is that again there are phase
transitions
here and here what uh what this is a
figure for
from a paper in which we studied a bunch
of different
denoiser so this is this non-linearity
takes different forms the basic concept
is
that if you see something that is close
to zero you set it to zero
if you see something that is different
from zero you you try to leave it where
it is
and what you see now this is for sparse
vectors and what you see now is the
following that if you fix
you know a sparsity level
of your uh vector x naught
and now the equivalent of the snr
is the undersampling so
is you know the aspect ratio on this on
this matrix
if you fix epsilon and move the under
sampling you undergo
a phase transition and this phase
transition will depend on this
non-linearity
so below this this point
the algorithm reconstruct basically uh
doesn't reconstruct at all the the
original x naught and above it
reconstruct basically exactly
is for afg
yeah so so okay
now there are connections between these
for instance in doing convex
optimization
in particular if you take one of this
denoiser that is the
i think the blue one that is soft
thresholding
then this is the same phase transition
as l1 minimization is a reason for that
all right so what is the big picture
here so okay you can do all of these
analysis etc
uh uh what is the one line
summary there have been a lot of work in
this area these are only papers that are
very
very related to what i'm talking about
some from by people
in this in this audience but the
one-line summaries that is the same as
the picture that we saw in the case of
verification
okay and this is one picture to to to
show that
okay this is similar to what i have
before okay
so i fixed the level of sparsity and now
i trace two phase transitions
one is you know the information
directive phase transition
is what you would do
where the the the you know where the
phase transition sits
if you couldn't you know compute the
base posterior
of this model compute
conditional expectation of x given
vector y
of all the vector x given vector y
surprise surprise this
ideal algorithm that you cannot you know
it's non-polynomial algorithm
yeah works as soon as delta is below 0.2
for epsilon 0.2 works as soon as delta
is 0.2
this basically means that it works it
reconstructed
reconstruct x from as many observations
as unknowns plus small of n
this is kind of you know surprising
then you look at what this you know
local algorithm
achieve if you uh just assume that you
know the prior
but you force yourself to use local
algorithms so
a certain class of polynomial time
algorithm
you get a bit worse this is uh
i don't remember what is the
distribution here that we use is
probably somewhere
a little bit worse quite a bit worse
and then this is what you get if you
don't know the prior distribution so
there is an extra loss
so at high level so the first line is
somehow new because it's
related to the fact that you don't know
the distribution of x but all the other
lines are the same
as before so you have a phase transition
for local algorithms
and this is this one w1 you have a phase
transition that is informatic
information theoretic this is the red
one
so this is was actually first
information theoretically
was proved that you can achieve it by by
hyung and sergio verdu
in this interval
between the red and the blue i don't
know of any polynomial algorithm that
does the compress sensing reconstruction
but you can modify your sampling matrix
your your sensing metrics using the same
trick of
spatial coupling this was first uh
suggested by kuder karp pfister and then
by florente ladders
and then we proved it and you can
squeeze this
phase transition to zero so there are
matrices
such that you can hit the vector with
that matrix
and then reconstruct with the polynomial
algorithm
and do it from a number of observations
that is the number of noon zeros plus a
small oven
yeah so the minimax refers to you know
the velocity level
you know the sparsity level max over the
distribution
of the excess zero support
okay but you say it's mini max face
charge for local algorithms
about the best algorithm a good question
the best algorithm you know if you don't
put polynomial constraint
is this if you put polynomiality
constraint that the question is really
hard right if you
can prove a lower bound for all
polynomial algorithms but didn't you say
the bias
like the diagonal
the the blue ones you know
the optimal thing you do the base
posterior with respect to mmsc this is
the base
of the baby but this is not
computationally effective
that is computing for instance e of x
given y
f vector x given the vector y
okay can you explain further why they're
the same picture
or that's it so i don't have time
five minutes to explain anything right
thank you
so i want to give you one more example
because this is actually
so in this uh okay it's interesting
so so so if you are you know a positive
you know a half you know glass half full
person you say okay this is nice because
you can get pretty good reconstruction
etc i'm a you know
glass of empty kind of person and
you know when i see this picture i find
very interesting
this frustrating region in which you can
meet the reconstruction
okay so this is an example in which the
frustrating region becomes huge
okay let me again motivate it from
coding theory
and then motivate it using i mean it's a
kind of
a dark motivation for this workshop is
not really was a
you know our motivation but using ldgm
so what is ldgm
is you know you have a vector of bits
and now you use this graph to compute
parity bits so you compute mod two sums
of this bit and this is what you send
through the channel and the graph is
sparse
okay so what an ldgm does for instance
fountain codes are you know a very nice
example of ldgm but
here i'll take regular ldgms so each
time i take
four bits and i take the mod to sum of
those four bits
and i send it through the channel so
this get
added noise now
this you can write in zero one notation
or in plus minus one notation so now
the mod to sum becomes multiplication so
you take
four plus minus one science and you send
it through the channel
other four and you send three channels
etc and each transmitted symbol
is the combination of foreign formation
symbols
okay now let me add another twist to
this you know in ldgm normally you send
a number of bits that is proportional to
the number of unknown bits
but let me do a twist i'll do i'll send
the number of bits that
is equal to n choose k so if i take
combinations of k bits i send all
the entries key combinations through
this noisy channel
and i'll add gaussian noise so this is
the model for each couples
i send this k bits
i add gaussian noise and this is what i
receive
now this i can write in tensor notation
what i'm doing is that i'm taking
a vector x and taking the outer product
of it k times add you know multiply by
coefficient and that caution noise
okay so the real motivation why we
studied this is that this is
currently a topic that has inter
attracted quite some interest in machine
learning
how you do data analysis where your data
form a tensor
and this is a very simple model for this
the model is the following
i have an unknown signal
i take the outer product of the signal
with itself k
times and i add gaussian noise
there is a simple in the case k equal to
of this problem is something that has
been studied in
uh tens dozens or hundreds of papers in
statistics is called the spiked
model so this is a spiked tensor
is also model motivation for yesterday
sorry yeah yeah the open problem is is
more general
okay now what is the same you know the
big picture is very similar to ldpc
codes
but now the gap is huge
now the only thing here it doesn't make
a lot of sense to talk of
special coupling of course
uh uh but what's interesting is the
following in this problem
you can you know compute what is the
information you know we proved
some simple upper and lower bounds so
what is the information theoretic phase
transition
so the phase transition if you do the
optimal reconstruction
and this is a signal-to-noise ratio
equal one
if you scale things in the in the right
way
so the right scaling it's this if you do
the right scaling then
the snr for the information theoretic
phase transition is some constant
okay
you can you know it should have a sharp
threshold
now if you if you if you look try local
algorithms
you get that this works when you know
the snr is bigger than basically
n to the k over two there is a slightly
smarter thing than local algorithm that
it's called matrix unfolding and if you
ask me a question i will explain what it
is
and this achieves n to the k over four
and there is you know oh
between one and this and to the zero but
there is no
no polynomial algorithm is known in this
interval
so there is a diverging with with the
sides interval
in which everything feels
okay so it's interesting that this is
very different from the classical
statistics case that is k equal to is
standard principle component analysis in
that case there is no gap there is a
phase transition in which just computing
the principal vector
works and below that no algorithm can
work
and this is called the you know
sometimes the bend bike metal
special is transition for something
did you assume this part so what that's
assumption
no norm one
okay so these are one simulation so k
equals two is just matrix pca right
yes yeah so you have you you just
compute the
principal eigenvector of the matrix and
this
as the optimal threshold
that is you know snr equal one
so this is how it works in simulation if
you if
this is a bunch of algorithms these are
all local algorithms and this is uh
this is all metrics unfolded based
algorithm and this is
standard local algorithm and this is
and then gets larger everything fails
eventually
okay
but i think it's okay
and uh yeah i think that uh
there is this convergence between
several team has been taking place for a
few years but
you know number of open problems that
are interesting increase
it's a faster pace
everybody's
so what is your major time for the album
you just string out the tensor as a
matrix
sort of in half and over two yeah so and
uh
and then if okay you can think of doing
it recursively
yeah now if you're interested in the
literary reconstruction error what you
want to do is
empirically we don't have any theorem
you want to do that
and then on top of that do some gradient
optimization
for instance power method or whatever
you want
but uh yeah if you're just interested in
the threshold
what you said is as good as anything i i
could think of
and if you have any bet does it mean if
you know how to solve
k minus one tensor you use no no i
recursively i mean what i mean if
you know if you have a tensor of order
16
so you do it uh n by n to the eighth by
n to eight and then you get the tensor
of order eight i mean the solution is a
tensor of order eight
and now i enter the 4 by n to the 4
now i get the solution tensor of order 4
etc i mean when
when i am full the time sort of the
solution that i get is
i mean you have to to you know it's good
to go get it
you know same size the solution that you
get is also a tensor of lower order
so in this tensor problem versus
the coding theoretic problem that you
map this tensor problem from
a little different right there you have
m2 different products whereas
here you have more data in a specific
additional structure
yeah so the upper bounds on the error
for the tensor problem also carry over
there
uh no i think that
you know okay so i think that if you do
the analysis in that case you can
you can get similar things but you will
not if if the graph is parsed you will
not get a
diverging gap you will get a gap that is
all
order one and somehow depends on the
degree of the graph
this is my guess this is the same as you
get in ldpc codes but
for ldgm codes right
yeah so this is kind if you want to
think of
it as a code is a code in which you're
sending a very small
rate of a very noisy channel
so andrea i thought you said in the last
problem you were discussing that
spatial coupling didn't apply or no it
doesn't yeah it's difficult to justify
right encoding theory can justify
because
very well because you can say okay i
designed the metrics
in uh compressed sensing can justify ah
so and so right because uh
you know you have some space for
designing the sensing metrics but you
are very constrained from the system
here is really our motivation was really
machine learning there you get so
typically what people are interested in
is stuff like
yeah you have data about users products
and days of the year right this is a
data site right
so you cannot impose of course you can
if you want to to work on it then you
can probably
you know you you you
you know right it's like an lgm you do
an lg in ldgm
i think we should wrap up